the challenge posed by the rise of China
phenomenally successful few decades that
China has had going from extreme poverty
to the world's second largest economy
has posed the question does this
challenge quite fundamental beliefs that
we have had about what makes for success
and what makes for a well-functioning
state to my immediate right is UJ
otherwise known as cherry who who is the
head of China foresight LSE ideas London
School of Economics
to my left Jeremy Waldron who is
professor of political philosophy of law
I beg your pardon Lord and to my far
left Deirdre McCloskey distinguished
economists so we're going to begin by
inviting us because it did just give us
said their take on whether a more
powerful government strengthens an
economy or not
so Deirdre would you know I don't
country to what you what you said a few
seconds ago I don't think we've tried in
the recent modern world free economies
very much here's what I mean most people
in this audience sir would I would call
themselves people of the left broadly
and even in my own country which is
supposed to be so conservative most
intellectuals are left-wing in the sense
that they want large a very large
government by historical standards the
most oppressive tyrannies in history
have not had as large a share of the
resources of the economy as a modern
state like the United States government
or the the government of France has so I
I think the reason people think that
well authoritarian governments alike and
they always mentioned
I'm Singapore if they're sophisticated
and China they do well hmm maybe a
liberal liberalism is a good idea for
the economy and you have to get kind of
scientific about this because on average
no tyrannies and especially big
government tyrannies are bad for the
economy take a look at East Germany
versus West when the wall came down was
discovered that East Germany had a much
much lower income than West Germany on
average and if you don't like that North
and South Korea most tyrannies don't
work out very well and it is true that
China's economic liberalisation after
1979 was successful
slowly successful I know some of the
people who advised the advise the
Communist Party on this and the
Communist Party owns the land gives
people 99-year leases and then since 79
stop doing stupid things like the Great
Leap Forward and the Cultural Revolution
and started to do what a modestly
intelligent government should do which
is Platt the land and allow people long
leases and then leave them alone and say
go ahead you you can do what you want
and it was it was a success but notice
that it's a success in India too after
1991 India's into bitterly a democracy
it's crazy but it's a democracy and it
is a liberal democracy more and more
these days since 1991 and economic
growth there has streaked ahead of what
it was under the license raj under the
ill-begotten influence of a London
School of Economics left-wing on the
Indian government Gandhi and narrow the
Gandhi's in narrow and so forth
attempting to do western-style socialism
in an extremely poor country and now
going from one dollar a day to
more like what 10 $15 a day so it's not
true that you get better results with
tyranny if you got the right tirant
deterrent there it's a good word tyrant
as in as in Singapore a guy is
intelligence as well it's let's let
capital capitalism work then it works
out but if you got a fool like an chroma
or contrast Zimbabwe with Botswana
Botswana is a liberal economy with a
safety net and not against that and it
works really well it's one of the most
successful sub-saharan African countries
and Zim is a basket case so take your
pick
you can either have a gang of fools
governing you or you can have a varied
market it's not true that economic power
is the same as political power political
power is backed by the state's good
legitimate monopoly of violence I don't
want a bunch of competing I don't want a
bunch of mafioso you're running around
competing with the state I agree with
that one one monopoly of violence but I
regard but but the market but by
contrast you know you're not compelled
to buy New Balance shoes could say ah
the international corporation terrible
power of the International Corporation
it's nothing like the power of your look
local council your local council can tax
you and put you in jail if you don't pay
it if you want to build a shack in the
backyard for your rakes you have to get
planning permission and if you don't get
it they'll make you tear it down whereas
New Balance if you don't buy their shoes
they'll weep but that's all they can do
to you so
stop worrying about international
corporations thank you very much all
right
government ok strong government um what
can I say in here I'm not coming here to
define my government because I very much
disagree with something they have done
in the past few years but what I'm
trying to say in here's ever since the
collapse of let's say they the collapse
of Soviet Union and the way seems to
predict China going to end up in the
same path you know that's really the
true the end of history moment what I'm
trying to say in here is if we look at
title today Authority liberty and wealth
I know it would say in short term the
authority and wealth go together because
China start from a very low base of you
know less much less than $1 a day of
having the basic income so what are we
talking about in here is really the
absolute deprivation ups and poverty
Chinese government tried to tackle in
the past 40 years but now to go forward
the difficulties will be on on the
relative deprivation you know whether
the party and the government will be
able to satisfy for those who have not
benefited from the economic reform in
the past 40 years and that's I think to
doubt with that sense of economic
inequality is the really the big
question and a major challenge for the
trans Commerce party and we see whether
they can take that challenge if they
cannot unafraid Francis Fukuyama was
right that will be the end of history
thank you a couple of perspectives there
it's it's undeniable that the Chinese
economy has been has grown a lot shall
we say you know probably since 76 but
but subsequently since 1992 it has been
dierdre's contention that that that
liberalism is the key to economic growth
so how do we square that circle this is
not a liberal state this is not a
liberal state and we need to remember
that I think the first thing to remember
is that a point that Deirdre made at the
very beginning it's going to depend on a
lot of circumstances it's going to
depend a lot on who the strong man or
the strong person is in charge of the
government if you have air21 and Turkey
you're going to have a little bit of
economic collapse under different
circumstances in China you have a lot
of economic progress what I think we
should focus on are two questions one is
what lessons should we draw for our
faith and democracy from these rival
stories of strong authoritarian
government because that's how the debate
is being set up that's how that's why
we're all here today it's our our faith
and democracy is shaky our faith and
democracy is not what it was
should that lack of faith be reinforced
by this this point about and the second
thing is to focus in on in what sense of
these governments more powerful what
powers do they have to affect the the
economy that our governments in the West
for example lack because we hear a lot
about more powerful governments more
authoritative governments more
authoritarian governments you don't get
a whole lot of specifics about what this
what this involves and I I hope as the
debate goes on this afternoon we can
focus on that one thing to remember is
that authoritarianism in a country like
China is not just a genial and polite
refusal to hold multi-party elections
authoritarianism means that gatherings
like this would be highly suspect
enormous ly nervous if they were
permitted at all thank you all of you
for answering your question for being
with us thank you
[Applause]